olá pessoal sejam limpos há mais um
vídeo e hoje vou ensinar como fazer um
compressor de ar uma maneira bastante
parado
isso claro se você já tiver uma
furadeira em casa
no total isso custou menos de dois euros
é esse projeto pode ser muito útil para
vocês vêem vários vossos computadores
uma vez que o jato d'água aqui é muito
forte e é muito forte porque a abertura
por onde o ar sai é de mais ou menos 2
milímetros
e se você não conseguir limpar o assunto
durante o espírito algumas partes
tekitos volta de certeza
aí está também pode ser usado para
oxigenar a água por exemplo seja com a
pesca num sítio e querem levar o peixe
vivo para o outro lugar pode multiplicar
lá por exemplo é vocês durante a viagem
poder ou assinando balde de água usando
isto e se os países não vão morrer pelo
caminho
ae
ó
o o o foco
o o o visto para vocês têm que utilizar
uma cola ideal para borracha no lixo que
esta partida vai apanhar bastante então
se vocês não usarem uma boca e isso vai
estragar seu rápido evento
então antes de vocês comprarem cola
company ler o rótulo de ver se dá para
látex ou não
ae
quebrou só estamos a chegar ao fim eu
espero que tenham gostado deste vídeo e
esta semana vai ter três vídeos no canal
e eu ainda não sei quando é que vai ser
o terceiro preciso da vossa ajuda para
escolher tem três opções a primeira é um
avião foi definida 3d que voa
depois tem uma espada dop contemplei do
tempo aí eu já fiz há bastante tempo
atrás então lembrei de fazer um vídeo e
depois tenho uma xingando com tambor
rotativo que dispara elásticos a isso
deixe nos comentários
e qual é o vídeo que vocês gostariam que
eu fizesse isso
muito obrigado vestido espero contar com
o vosso haiti nem isso até a próxima